cocaine it's a hell of a drug it's also
hella expensive an Eightball an eighth
of announcer 3.5 grams costs around $250
in the US but what's the real price of
that little baggie to figure it out you
have to go from farm to glass table it
all starts with the coca leaf which
grows in bushes along the Andes three
South American countries grow pretty
much the world's entire supply Peru
Colombia and Bolivia farmers pick the
leaves year round but make very little
in Colombia they get a dollar and ten
cents per kilo of leaves in Peru four
dollars and thirty cents many in the
region have traditionally chewed or
brewed a leaf here or there to treat
altitude sickness
but to get that other canna high you
need a literal ton of leaves it takes a
thousand kilos more than 2,000 pounds of
leaves just to produce 1.61 kilos of
Coca paste a masticated mess that's the
first step towards cocaine sometimes
farmers themselves make the paste a
process that can involve cement liquid
fertilizer sulfuric acid and gasoline
YUM the paste sells for more than a
thousand dollars per kilo in Colombia
next up cocaine base and finally cocaine
hydrochloride or street cocaine
processing this usually happens in
extremely sophisticated labs with
chemicals like hydrochloric acid and
potassium permanganate at this point
it's time for cocaine to leave the Andes
for good from Peru Colombia and Bolivia
the drug gets trafficked around the
world to countries like Brazil Chile and
Argentina where it's either sold or sent
onwards to transit hubs like Jamaica or
West Africa from there it's a quick
jaunt to Western Europe stateside 95% of
all cocaine to the US goes through
Mexico or its waters and more than half
of that cocaine has made a stop in
Central America so who's flying the
small planes navigating the backroads
hiding grams and shipments of pineapples
it's a true story I'm pretty much
finding every creative manner Under the
Sun to transport cocaine
the cartels Mexican cartels like Sinaloa
los zetas and La Familia Michoacana had
the major hand in the trade Colombia
also has a number of cartels not to
mention the guerrilla group FARC that
managed smuggling routes and organized
crime syndicates from Honduras to West
Africa and elsewhere are also involved
cartels will do practically anything to
make sure that nothing gets in their way
Latin America and the Caribbean have
among the highest violent crime rates in
the world in large part because of the
drug trade millions have had to flee
their homes in Colombia more than 60
thousand Mexicans have been killed since
2006 and over tens of thousands of
parents have sent their children across
the us-mexico border
undocumented and alone all because of
drug-related violence all this for 17
point two million cocaine users around
the world most of them in the United
States Brazil and Western Europe
Americans spent twenty eight billion
dollars on cocaine in 2010 alone to put
it into perspective those people could
have funded the National Cancer
Institute for almost six years
so from Livelihood spent to thousands of
miles traveled and thousands of lives
lost is a few hundred dollars for an
Eightball a fair price what do you think
[Music]
but if the drug war is being lost and
hundreds of thousands of people have
been killed then why does it continue